hi Matt Welch here with a ridiculous hat
on I'm with my co-author Nick Gillespie
of the Declaration of Independence with
a tea asks on ask a libertarian day
we're reaching our six of his exercise
and we had the next question via
Facebook I believe Nancy Edwards ley
shinging I'm going to pronounce her name
arbitrarily asks this as a libertarian
with a very slight conservative leaning
comma lol with a lot of religious
conservative friends I would really
appreciate a good synopsis of religion
from the libertarian point of view so
could I get it from you etc yeah I mean
I think a couple things about that one
is that religion has proved to be beyond
the family probably the one kind of
voluntary community group whose missions
and objectives and community can kind of
go across generations across time I
think religion in general has been a
force for good it is often a force for
repression suppression and violence but
what is the particular interest for me
about religion and libertarianism is
that coming out of the religious wars of
Europe and especially England in the
17th century the concept of toleration
the company the concept of the right of
conscience that you have the right to
worship God as you see him whereas you
don't see him and you should be left
alone as not as long as long as you are
not infringing on other people's rights
to voluntarily do the same everything's
good so I think religion has been a very
powerful force for libertarian ideas for
individualism and generally for good one
of the things that we talk a lot about
here at reason Jesse Walker's pieces
come to mind is the free market that we
have in religion and in religious
products and expression everywhere that
you see in America that you don't see in
for instance Moore Old Europe type of
places which tend to have a single
dominant religion that's that's always
butting heads with a secular state in
America since it's founded on religious
tolerance there is much more of a sense
of expression and
Azzam of this and as a non-member or a
member of no church at all I see this as
as a good thing and one of the one the
great credits to the United States the
deregulation effect of deregulation of
religious practice in America and in the
West more broadly is one of the you know
people used to fear that that would lead
to chaos and instability and to violence
and in fact it solved the religious
violence problem in the West and one
hopes that it gets taken up with all
possible speed throughout the world